[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com you'll look better but more
importantly
you'll feel better unless you have kovid
then you'll probably die
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
changes
[Music]
mmm that is refreshing yeah that's uh
today i have a little bit of lime
seltzer water now i already had my
coffee
really and it's just uh you know it's
it's almost a little effervescent oh
just like you you know it's really nice
carbonated milk
what ah what the ah i make it myself
yeah is there like an eclair or
something like that
no i have no idea hey we have a lot to
get to today that's true i'm really
excited so
one thing that people been talking about
quite a bit you know how divisive trump
was yeah
i've heard divisive but i don't like it
i'll just say interchangeable
biden is far worse and i'll lay out the
case as to why uh we'll also
be talking about uh well the prime
minister sorry president of the
philippines
but vaccines butt vaccines
along with uh the american flag today
and its history because macy gray
apparently needed some press but
it's going to be a a lot of fun uh
gerald jumble
boy that green goblin missed an
opportunity
i'll get you you may see gray
saved us all willem dafoe is it's like
if christopher walken one of those
dinosaurs that you know you
you get in the cereal box and you add
water and it's like if you uh didn't add
the water
just shriveled up he's a he's a he's a
christopher walker who's been putting a
meat dehydrator yeah yeah it's like if
you hit steve buscemi with a hammer a
bunch of times
yeah and then like sun dried them like a
raisin yes
all right why aren't they brothers in
more movies well that's how he got
started he was one of the california
raisins
um all right all right g morgan junior
gerald how are you
i am well how are you sir i'm doing uh
pretty well good i'm doing pretty well
how are you
well you know what i just uh i'm
clearing up the nasal thing though okay
good yeah
which is nice i'm still i'm still
coughing up you know blood but baby
steps
quarter black how are you i'm offended
that you said christopher walking in
that
uh he didn't willem dafoe i know i said
was a green goblin yeah but then you
went to christopher walken yeah but that
has nothing to do with it
neither one of them are your people be
more
tribal you missed the point well there's
a pretty good dj what is it slim video i
forget
that's true oh yeah yeah that's true
that boy slim bad boy
batboy slim spicy corrected it all right
dave landau is here and you have a show
coming up uh
yeah i do i got a couple oh look at how
i'm hungry
and i still look terrible but i'm
starving i miss breakfast tonight so
beautiful i'm sorry i gotta get off
track
am i hurting myself yeah uh this uh this
weekend you can see me in buffalo new
york i also have dates in des moines
iowa and columbus ohio coming up
uh uh and in minnesota buffalo might
have the first socialist mayor
is that true that's true it's true
happening right now and she looks about
exact picture in your mind's eye right
now okay what a socialist
mayor looks like yeah correct really
that unappealing yes that unappealing so
here before we get to
anything else what they're talking about
in cnn oh they're talking about how uh
it's a violation of human rights to uh
require identification
dang it you know in the united states
we're trying to entice people with
donuts with lotteries to get the vaccine
because you know freedom
and uh in the philippines though they're
president
rodrigo duterte i don't know if i'm
saying that correctly but i don't care
it's largely an irrelevant country manny
pacquiao and stick fighting
what else you got you stick things cool
um he has
taken a different tack and i i
hate it because he's fascist and it's an
abusive rights
but i love it because we host an
entertainment program
[Music]
says you will get vaccinated otherwise i
will order a tally
of people who have not been vaccinated i
will not inject them with ivermectin
which is intended for pigs
if not i will there is a national
emergency
i'll have you arrested sent to prison
and i'll inject the vaccine in your butt
i love how i love how the president of
the philippines
is just immediately admitting the
corruption and the
standards oh yeah here we complain about
the prison industrial complex we're like
you know they're staying there too long
he's like
in our prisons uh our guards don't do
work they don't show up
there's rape it's very unclean so i want
to go there it's really punishment
they have no standards we have no
standards at all i mean it's coverage of
this was like well that's one way to get
you know the job done and make sure
people get vaccinated it's gonna be nice
to hear it take away from a
cell door just closed behind you and a
big guy sitting and they're like
yeah i'm vaccine yeah i'm vaccine
you be butt i think you should get down
on your knees this seems unfair
i'll start with you so uh by the way you
go to crowdershop.com if you want to
support this show look
free speech matters shirt and uh the
best way to tune in is the live show
monday through thursday at 10
a.m eastern uh our final show before the
break before i go to get my
ah chest filet open for surgery early
july
is going to be uh tomorrow but we will
have uh uh i think like five episodes of
pre-taped
documentaries and change my mind's going
up and you're seeing dr nick riviera
yes what's the last day gonna be uh it's
gonna be thursday
tomorrow and that's going to be uh
california for cultural appropriation
months
because it it absolutely should not be a
part of the united states i thought it
broke off and
sank into the ocean no i just where is
uconn cornelius when you need him
i watched 2012 my axe pick him off and
queers
nothing it's surrender it's burning but
surrounded by water that won't put it
out yeah can you just leave me napa
i just i'll take that yeah well yeah you
can yeah
you can take napa and pull some street
fare yeah no no no no no no
it's a package you want to be the
world's most powerful genie everything
that comes with it you get the folsom
street
you're also gonna have to fight a lot of
soccer moms for that property
a lot of novelty t-shirts it's one
o'clock i ate fruit for dinner i drank a
glass of wine don't talk to me until
i've had my two glasses of wine
it's one and finally my favorite just a
shirt for uh for zoloft i'm questioning
my life decisions
so this morning on cnn this is something
to want to you know a lot of people get
this wrong where they talk about like
cancel culture and they're trying to
change us to accountability culture
here's what the term canceled culture
i've talked about this it's not just
when someone says something that turns
their audience off for a perfect example
of that there could be no cancel culture
with comedians in other words
something like a louis ck someone like a
bill burr it doesn't matter because the
audience comes to see them
cancel cultures when you have people in
disproportional positions of power
who try to force someone out of the
limelight because
they hold an opinion that isn't even
necessarily congruent with the rest of
the public that's the thing
that's what canceled culture is it's not
accountability when the people at
you know cnn msnbc are the ones trying
to get someone cancelled and they happen
to be effective or youtube facebook
twitter so
cuban they were talking about just
i think i think his uh yeah he has it's
jeffrey one hand clapping tubing ah
so this morning perfected it
what's that that's our most esteemed
commentator
[Laughter]
he analyzes civilizations cut his feed
cut it
he analyzes situations but can't analyze
what to do during a phone call
no it's a zoom call i'm sorry same so
this morning on cnn they were talking
about lin-manuel miranda
you know he's a guy created hamilton
yeah uh and in the heights i guess is
this new
film adapted i don't know if it's
adapted from play so what happened is
there were some outrage and i think this
is silly
that there weren't enough uh afro
dominicans is that the
black dominican americans in this
neighborhood and they're talking about
the guy who by the way uh
like a brian selter i was sure was gay
until i found out like show tunes
you hear him speak true no he's just
he's he's just who he be
totally a lot of people think lin-manuel
miranda is not what he be but it do
yeah uh and they were talking about in
response to
the people who were outraged of him not
having enough black dominicans in in the
heights and this is an actual
a serious discussion that took place
on america's most trusted news they say
that free speech is on the line
you're not allowed to say anything but
that's not actually that's what's
happening sure
people are able to speak their minds and
say what they believe
the question is how is the marketplace
going to respond how is your audience
going to respond so in this specific
case
in the heights people are saying well
what more do you want right you made the
founding fathers black and now people
are still giving you a hard time
the neighborhood that the heights is
about which is about half a mile from
where i live in harlem
is majority afro-dominican so imagine
making a movie about greenwich
connecticut with no white actors
people would say make that make sense or
making a play of the founding fathers
with no white actors
he did he made a play with the founding
fathers black and then not enough black
people in a dominican neighborhood it'd
be like having a play that should be
about white people historically
with uh no white people did cell phone
much
oh yeah also i'd love to see the hear
the phone call yeah i have a hot script
hollywood
it's all white people in connecticut yes
yes hello
it sounds very interesting no there's no
there's no uh lesbian couple adopting a
child hello hello hello hello
are you back they keep hanging up have
you seen liz hyper on line 12
yeah bridgeton has a black queen beauty
and the beast has black people in
positions of power at a time when that
didn't happen in england and by the way
i don't really care i mean i think the
rapping is pretty crappy
but then again when they're you know
their standard bears takashi 69 i don't
think this generation knows a whole lot
about hip-hop
that being said bar is low that i know
it sounds like an old man that's not
music no it's not it's
not only is it not music it's a
buttersoft [ __ ] who snitched
and got out of prison due to his asthma
and coveted that's
back in our day you did your time and
suge knight dangled you from a third
story balcony okay
yep better cash those ninja turtles to
royalty checks we know how it worked
it's not a world i respect
it's not a generation i respect you can
comment if it irritates you and if you
don't like that side go over to bad boys
records get yourself life after death
go on or death row um
so this is funny to me that she didn't
understand were you about to say
something yeah i just i i couldn't
believe this i watched this live i'm so
glad we added this to the show this
morning because i watched you
you were watching it live while i was
watching it yes it's like kevin
mcallister and his mom looking at the
christmas tree
pretty much except with hate yeah so
both of us hate this and essie cup's
like oh of course yeah they're
totally strong like okay fine here prove
my point for me
one of you say something controversial
go one of you
not one of you is going to say anything
remotely controversial and it's not just
you made a great point it's gatekeepers
yeah it's people saying you can't say
this not on audience not advertisers
it's it's also disproportionate on your
opinion you can say horrific things if
you're a democrat
really terrible things about republicans
well hold on this isn't that terrible
but i'm going to show you the next
this is again where we're talking about
appeasing or trying to apologize to the
mob now
i've always said your words don't define
you your actions define you
and generally speaking your words the
way you speak the way you carry yourself
is a reflection of your character as are
your actions they should be
relatively in line with each other
however we see this on cnn
and sc cup is really like the the white
anna navarro you know was like i was
she was like i was a republican on what
nothing
nothing ever but take my word i have
credibility i don't like donald trump
and
i was a republican really what did you i
don't know
so anyway she's the white equivalent
where she just claimed she was a
republican dyn's
on that for years and they actually uh
show you
that it doesn't matter what you do if
you've said naughty words
but they'll forgive violent felonious
actions
yeah if you're of the right political
persuasion or skin color
this next clip yeah i'll tell you mel
gibson michael vick
blew my mind but not really so the
question is who is your audience and are
you smart enough to know and figure that
out who is mel gibson's audience
well who's everyone braveheart [ __ ]
about when have people done enough to
redeem themselves and i think that's a
very real question
is when is somebody worthy of
forgiveness you take someone for example
like michael vick
did something terrible was convicted
paid the cost for that served his time
and then came out and did a tremendous
amount of work
in supporting animal rights and when you
speak to people in those communities
they say no we feel like this was
genuine
okay okay so here's the deal mel gibson
said
bad words while drunk yeah no one's
saying you didn't say bad things while
drunk
most hilarious voicemails ever recorded
very funny he called the cop
sugar tits who was a guy how is that not
hysterical but i understand holocaust
denial bad i get it i'm not absolving
them that however
bad words while drunk they are saying is
more impermissible
than a man who drowned and electrocuted
dogs
alive wow come on
come on think about that for a second oh
he could why do you think michael vick
can be forgiven
and they try to pull who watches mel
gibson um like everyone okay
he has done some of the biggest films of
all time doesn't mean i even love them
all right
but he is a monumentally successful
filmmaker
you guys wanted him out he's not
you guys for some reason allowed michael
vick to be back in the good graces i
don't
i don't know if you agree with this what
do you think is worse anti-semitic
tirades when
uh calling drunkenly your gold-digging
girlfriend and offering her one more
chance mind you
or no chance or
kill drowning electrocuting strangling
dogs alive who want nothing more than to
be loyal to you and you like me and by
the way michael vick didn't walk up to
the police station and say officers
you know like he didn't come in and say
i'm doing this please forgive me he said
oh crap i got caught now i need to do
something to rehab my image now he may
be genuinely court-ordered redemption
yeah
exactly so that it makes it it makes a
difference you didn't turn yourself in
right you actually get caught and we're
like oh crap i'm really sorry yeah
you're sorry you got caught
okay i think redemption is redemption as
horrible as that is
you're allowed to change your life right
i really do think that and i think in
same with mel gibson
i also think i don't know what work
though has michael vick been doing with
all these animals he threw some uh he
threw some spray paint on people coming
out of a tj maxx in fur coast oh that's
exciting yeah
he volunteered at a kill shelter yes
yeah
at that point gonna do it anyway might
as well get paid i got the experiment
come on man oh man community therapy
no you're totally right dave like you
can be redeemed i'm not i'm not saying
that at all i'm just saying that it's
that this is the pattern for the left
it's somebody who gets caught like jimmy
kimmel didn't go in and say guys look
i've been doing blackface for a long
time and i'm really sorry about it
somebody put the video back out there
and he's like oh crap i have to respond
to this that's a different situation you
can
totally respond and say i'm sorry and
mean it i i definitely believe that yeah
but it's not like these people went out
there and did it on their own accord
saying gosh i i just think
i just think it's bad it's very clear
that the left will forgive violent
action yeah absolutely you think if a do
you think of a white male conservative
was burning dogs alive electrocuting
dog's life sorry i don't wanna i don't
wanna be hyperbolic
do you think that uh they would be
forgiven
maybe cats
terrible i'm kidding i love anthony i
like generals more than people yeah
if you really want to who are mad i
still enjoy a good
mel gibson in other words they would
soon fathers they would sooner forgive
the man who kills his dog
than the one who names his dog himmler
what malcolm and you shouldn't do either
stupid i learned that with little mr
gobbles i learned my lesson
mel gibson is insane though and that's
why i enjoy him yes
that's simple everyone knows that rant
priest and said you
are awful you have no soul you have no
soul but then he tries to save face
because he's drunk and crazy he goes
but i will give you one more chance like
you're not negotiating
that's like buying with putin you're a
killer but you know
we can have we could go get ourselves a
slice
yeah look at that shiner i went to she
promised hot tub festivities
didn't live up to it right and the man
got mad the man he deserves it
he deserves it it's like what do you
want him to do he came home as mel
gibson right
come on come on you wait so uh this is
another story ikea is now under fire for
creating
this is one that look i don't think it's
that bad but they should have seen this
coming
for creating an african-american themed
menu
forces and this was sent out to some
workers in uh atlanta
from ikea oh in atlanta to honor the
person or at least the atlanta employees
were meant to honor the perseverance of
of to honor the perseverance of black
americans and acknowledge the progress
yet to be made
we observe juneteenth on saturday june
19th
and then it says look at our special
menu on saturday which will include
fried chicken watermelon mac and cheese
potato salad collard greens candied yams
and white hoods
so the black the black employees were
outraged
calling it racist and demeaning which
look it's hilarious it's
tone deaf yeah that being said ikea did
apologize and uh for the remainder of
pride month they'll continue um
serving their regularly scheduled fare
so yeah they're gonna yeah it's just oh
okay swedish meatballs yeah it's just
the swedish chef
demanding you look at me version
my version don't just cake leave the
frosting in the trains and
slurp a slurpee derpy oh just stick to
cinnamon rolls guys come on
in fairness that menu looks delicious it
does actually look real i'm gonna give
you the
burton vaccine and like you could point
me to some racist food
and i'm gonna go i don't know how it's
racist because i like it because it
looks delicious exactly
that's what i had uh on saturday on
sunday father's day
oh i love it fried chicken we had
watermelon it's in season
now if in you know the middle of
february you're seeking out some
watermelon
nothing like perpetuating the original
stereotype but you do you you got a
problem
i love february melon yes no i don't
even know
uh so claire's by the way happy birthday
right now this is something else before
we get to the different policies of
donald trump and joe biden again
i will argue that joe biden has divided
america more than
any president in record time and i
understand i'm not saying that donald
trump was not divisive
but for two very different reasons but
right now i do want to honor someone
obviously observing clarence
thomas oh justice clarence thomas uh
here is a he by the way for people who
don't know
he's the guy who made that guy andrew
breitbart a conservative
andrew breitbart tuned in to try and
watch this guy get read the riot act and
watch his career and then he said
they're lynching this guy you can go and
read his book the trial of clarence
thomas
specifically biden's treatment of him is
what led to andrew breitbart
becoming a conservative but uh i believe
we have uh oh yeah this is a this is a
classic a clip
of of clarence thomas obliterating
former vice president joe biden
this is a case in which this sleaze
this dirt was searched for by
staffers of members of this committee
was then leaked to the media
and this committee and this body
validated it and displayed it
at prime time over our entire nation
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
american as far as i'm concerned
it is a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves quote
we already have a [ __ ] mayor we don't
need any more [ __ ] big shots
niggered here nick now i just wanted
to show you the timeline because it's
not like he learned from it
just a side by side why are you so quiet
today dave i'm just hungry dude
yeah watermelon
uh and i understand he was quoting
someone else saying the n word i think
he said the n word something like
something like 16 times in the senate
quite a few what is it but
again just playing by their own rules
they should be canceled
yes and and well the honestly why is
being so quiet during that is i don't
i don't remember that speech that he
gave right
clearance that was during the
confirmation hearing yeah i remember it
happening now but i was just kind of
taken back by it for a minute because i
forgot how completely cruel that was
yes yeah it absolutely was but it just
shows you how times have changed if he
said anything close to that i mean um
you know
not accidentally like he did in the clip
that we have him here um then you would
see like
cancelled immediately right yeah i think
papa john's guy i think he was quoting
somebody there was another
guy who said he was quoting somebody
else and he was saying that it was bad
and yeah exactly he's like hey this is a
bad thing don't say this word
and says i hate when people ask me if
i've ever quoted anybody saying the
n-word
of course have you ever said have you
seen some of the guests we've had on the
show
i like they have had to address the
things that they've said 20 30
40 times right i just don't like though
when you see somebody in a position of
power like that
where they're reading the n-word because
they feel good like they want to do it
yeah and that's what you see i i find
that so disgusting
it's like oh boy i'm going to say it
today yeah you know
feel it give me somebody did someone get
my highlighter yeah you know what make
it i want i want it to be the pink blue
and yellow one i really want to make
this
just a party on my page yeah
you feel that though when somebody is
doing that deliberately right yeah being
able to say because he could have easily
said
n-word he's trying to get a rise out of
it absolutely and people don't remember
the the witch hunt that it was they
tried to bring out every negative
stereotype of clearance
oh he went to this porn shop which
turned out wasn't even a porn shop where
he could have been when he lived i
believe in dc at that time
they brought out these the worst thing
that clarence thomas did just to be
clear for people out there who don't
know
just like some people are familiar with
macy gray if i not with gen z is he said
hey who put uh who uh whose pubic hair
is on this diet coke can
that just makes me want to party with
clarence yes
it's hilarious you tell me do you want
to you want to go to a kegger with
clarence thomas
or sonia sotomayor that's a good thing
thomas she probably would be offended
about it she'd start an investigation as
to
who short and curly was on her zima well
here we are 30 years later that would be
that'd be about as scandalous as a
parking ticket right
you would think so yeah but no all right
uh i want to move on to this really
quickly this is uh this is something
we've heard this a lot right america is
more divided than ever before
yeah because of joe biden and by the way
you're out there you can hit the
notification bell because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot
um so just hit that ding it's a live
show monday through thursday 10am
eastern
um i think that it is so
woefully misguided and i understand that
it's by design with the media look
far be it for me to argue that donald
trump do you have your restless legs and
can you stop shaking your foot why is it
because you're hungry because it's like
it's like it's like you'd be lifting up
your knee and showing me you're mild to
it's because it's moderate to severe
plaque psoriasis fine he keeps shaking
his leg
i feel like he's trying to he's morphing
someone a bomb
sitting spread eagles honestly
i am more comfortable what does that say
about me
wait a minute i like it a lot so um
they've tried to argue that donald trump
is the most divisive president ever
yeah and uh i would say joe biden's more
devices but for two very very different
reasons donald trump was divisive here's
the reason why and this is just my
opinion and then i'll try and
substantiate it
all the links are available at
lottoscri.com every single
president before i should say certainly
every single democratic president before
donald trump you can go back to the bush
years and remember how they treated him
but at that point they still had some
semblance of attempting to appear
objective but of course we know that
they weren't we had eight years of
barack obama where was nothing but
fawning
over the president and of course at this
point new media started to emerge legacy
media tried to silence new media we saw
that happening
right we thought hey youtube facebook
twitter there are no more gatekeepers
and then these huge corporations spent
tons of money
to silence voices like yours truly many
of you out there
donald trump was divisive because he was
pointing out what we all knew for a long
time but too many people were afraid to
say including republicans
that the media was dishonest and that
the left were liars that they were
biased
that they were they were not well
intentioned and that they were lying
about it
so donald trump created a divide in
pointing that out
joe biden is divisive precisely because
he's one of those liars
exactly and i don't think joe biden
would be as divisive today
had it not been pointed out in other
words if we went from barack obama to
joe biden
a lot of americans right honest question
comment below
i used to talk about this when the show
was syndicated on radio before donald
trump was ever president
and i said there are a lot of people out
there who think that cnn is my god
objective journalism
and they believed it they believed it
until donald trump that's why we don't
go after msnbc because at least they're
honest about where they stand cnn was
exposed
abc nbc cbs new york times institutions
and the left think that's
thinks that's a bad thing that people
have have lost their trust in american
institutions do you mean wapo then sure
do you mean snopes absolutely do you
mean brian stelter okay
now biden tries to come back and act as
though this is business as usual
and there are a lot of people going wait
he's palming it so donald trump divisive
because he pointed out the lie
joe biden is divisive because now he's a
part of the lie
and no one believes the lie anymore yeah
absolutely and so when when you have
trump coming in he basically understood
a principle you don't sacrifice the
truth for unity doesn't mean he always
got everything right but unity was not
his goal doing what was right
in most of these situations with his
policies and what he would say about the
media
that was more important than unifying
people you had to point out the
hypocrisy
right now really quickly let me point
out just to kind of prove my point i
want you to see how the media treated
donald trump
versus joe biden i know you hear people
complaining about it a lot but i
actually want you to believe your line
eyes and lion ears here's some of the
greatest hits from the objective
journalists
as it relates to donald trump since
you're attacking us can you give us a
question
since you're no mr president-elect
[Applause]
since you are attacking our news
organization matt can you give us a
chance your organization you are
attacking our news organization
organization can you give us a chance to
ask a question sir
sir can you stay quiet mr
president-elect go ahead and you say
ask any question no president-elect can
you give us don't be attacking us
can you give us a question don't be a
question
i'm not going to give you can you can
you stay calm you are fake news let's go
ahead
cnn's fake news i don't think so i don't
take questions
cnn is fake news i don't take questions
from you but i'm
donald trump rants and raves at the
press i'm not ranting and raving i'm
just telling you you know you're
dishonest people
should i let him have a little bit more
what do you think peter peter should i
have
let him have a little bit of this sit
down sit down
man i just told him i've got to come
over and see the fake news
i miss the guy yeah i just tell them i
gotta come over and see the fake news
who do you mean
you and you and you and you and you
let's go i beg your wife whoa
i can't even believe that that office
has become now i know i know
oh now let's compare this to uh
former vice president joe biden and uh
how the press
treats him questions and as usual folks
they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on that
must be nice jonathan associated press
the perception of you that got you
elected as a moral
decent man is the reason why a lot of
immigrants are coming together
that's the perception of 100 of america
yeah how do you resolve
that tension over the years over your
career you've already spent a great deal
of time at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
except now you're living there and
you're president it's been four weeks
what's it like
chocolate chocolate chip oh look he just
discovered fire
which by the way is also how joe biden
would react
if he saw fire
you have a flint and a rock what's that
what's that device that creates the
magical heat it's a zippo
oh what are we doing that that ice cream
cone also laid him out for the next 72
hours
exactly i'm gonna do to take a nap oh my
god this is this is this this is turned
back
into liquid because it's a solid now it
turns into
i got the self-lubricating pocket
catheter
well i thought this was bad with barack
obama right the media gave him a huge
pass right
didn't do a whole lot of digging when he
was running for president didn't do a
whole lot when he started to
you know do his policies and do things
that we thought were bad it's gotten
worse under joe biden well it's gotten
worse because at least barack obama had
charisma right
yeah and i mean charisma he had charisma
but now they have to make up for that
also yeah so in other words with barack
obama they would be able to ask him a
question i don't know about policy
and he could shuck and jive which by the
way people should know out there they
tried to accuse sarah palin of being
racist and
recently i saw black commentators saying
that candace owens was
chucking and jiving and i said there's
no chuck it's shuck and give people like
oh that's a gotcha no
it's a term from slavery and if you're
talking about being a black lives matter
activist and supporting critical race
theory you should know what shuck and
jive means
it comes from being elusive to the slave
masters usually doing during corn
husking season
and then became common nomenclature in
boxing like he's pulling the shuck and
jive he's being evasive anyways they
would ask
barack obama a question he would chuck
and job not answer and they'd go thank
you very much and move on right with joe
biden because he doesn't have
any charm they have to say first before
i ask you a question
it's very clear that you are the
president near and dear to everyone's
heart
everyone loves you and you're super
super cool
now do you like stuff
do you remember where you are and this
wouldn't be so bad
if donald trump didn't rip off the
band-aid if donald trump didn't turn the
light on
so do we blame the man who turned the
light on
or do we blame the man who is now
shooting the lights back out or
attempting to
and this is something too objectively
this is happening uh
around the globe in my home country of
canada with prime minister blackface
and then even i think we have a clip
freight from australia yeah um
sky news and i used to appear on sky
news we were talking about debates
not friendly uh here's them talking
about
former vice president joe biden at the
g7 summit this is across
across the globe where their toilets
flush the other way listen to how
cnn is reporting this momentous event
joe biden is stepping under the world
stage for the first time as president
and equal to foreign leaders
now let's go back in time to 2018 and
see if those same newsrooms
offer the presidency of donald trump
such light and positive coverage
attic and deepening g7 divide better put
perhaps
as g6 just push them off edge
they're trying to give the illusion that
he doesn't have any disputes with any of
these international
uh leaders what do you think of that i
just think joe biden is
a lucky person he has got all the media
on his side or most of them
give me your wallet particularly cnn
completely at odds with what they did to
trump
so uh you know his popularity surely can
only win from this because he's getting
so much
positive pr through the journalists who
are
saying it's really quite appalling to
watch and what happened to
straight news reporting which doesn't
seem to be existent there well straight
news reporting
went uh out of style along with all
straight
news reporters um straight white news
reports yeah
gone forever now cnn it's all gay all
the time
and other times it's not gay it's still
kind of gay a little bit yeah
at times it's not gay it's well brian's
still there they say
i've never seen sky news that it's uh
that is smug
well what is it everybody's right it is
smoke one time when i was on sky news
the guy i was talking about why do you
this was in the uk though not australia
i don't know if it's i think they have
different networks he goes uh
well i certainly hope that you don't
have any firearms where you i said yeah
i do i have one at my hip right now
now why in the world would you have uh
would you have some kind of a firearm on
your hip right now i said
uh because i don't have the arm security
that you have in your building right
there with firearms he's like oh i don't
have any really you're gonna tell me
that
you don't have any security there at the
nearest building not at all i meant to
say i don't have any in front of me he
goes well i hope the safety latch is on
and i said what the hell is that
yeah and then you were if anyone did the
safety and were like catch
no it was by skype yeah but it would
have been fun catch
hot potato hot potato demasculine so
don't worry it's not loaded oh wait it
was
yeah i love that australia can see it
obviously these guys in australia
looking at going hey what
what the hell well australia is really
concerned about china and so australia
right now is actually saying hey guys we
should is anyone keeping an eye on this
because
they really are vulnerable in a lot of
ways they can be exposed so um
they haven't been nearly as
anti-american as a lot of other nations
have
usually when you meet australians
they're fun and they're drunks now
that's great
um this is also important so we should
look at the difference in
policies when people say donald trump
was divisive and they
they mean personality wise i guess
because as far as policies
really there wasn't anything all that
divisive and there shouldn't be
by its very nature in reducing the size
of government in my opinion
when you intrude into people's lives
like i don't know say shutting down a
business
or paying people unemployment in
perpetuity so that business owners
cannot hire them
or uh lock people at home and place
despite skyrocketing suicide
and allow felons back into the street
right and charge you for trying to
protect yourself from felons amid these
rights i would say those are more
divisive policies whereas donald trump
is like
rolling back taxes and regulations but
i want you to hear from uh straight from
the uh the horse's mouth
i guess it's a mr ed montage i don't
know i ran out of space
uh the media criticizing the most
divisive policies
of donald trump fundamental decision of
when a woman needs to make a decision
about when she's having children
how many children she's having under
what circumstances she is having them
that those are fundamentally her
decisions president trump tries to
create red herring arguments that don't
exist and he's lying to the american
people
anna navarro what do you think i think
i'm really sick
of this president and everybody who
works around him i used to be a
republican
you know it seems like everything they
utter is about ms-13
it seems that everything they utter is
about maligning the dreamers and
immigrants that come here
now to our worldly today a top
counter-terrorism official in the us is
now saying
that recent anti-muslim rhetoric is
making his job and the work of his
colleagues more difficult let's bring in
cnn's
jim sciutto and jim this official
specifically referenced anti-muslim
remarks
by president trump the trump white house
is canceling
race-related training sessions at
federal agencies yeah this memo says
it's come to the president's attention
that agencies have spent millions it
must have been post biden with clarence
thomas to believe
anti-american propaganda it came to the
president's attention
how you know how little how about you
answer how how about you answer how i
mean you should have enough room in that
chrome dome for a couple of answers for
crying out loud
or maybe some proof of how i think you
know how that happened really how
uh racism i don't know let me look at my
purse he has a purse
he does it's a immerse that's bad
we can bring that up for later in the
james o'keefe video that's the thing no
one was talking about
this the man carries a person you don't
want to get a briefcase in the crooks of
your elbow
i i know looking at him i would i would
assume he did yeah
well let me be really clear about uh
they were taught just addressing this
the really divisive
policies donald trump supported radical
measures like heartbeat pills when a
baby has its own heartbeat autonomously
from the mother
at that point it's considered ending a
life he didn't believe that we should be
funding abortion overseas meaning
american taxpayers look you may think
that you support the right to have an
abortion here in the country
you may even think that we should spend
some money in financial we should
provide financial aid to nations abroad
i disagree with both of those things
but if we're going to find common ground
can we at least agree that we should not
be funding abortions overseas in any
capacity
if you can't then don't tell me it's
about the first trimester second
trimester it's not about that you think
that american taxpayers
should be taxed more and we should
provide more money to abortions overseas
as a method of population control what
else do we have racist
his racist immigration stance legal
immigrants by the way that's what it is
legal immigrants coming through the
muslim ban identified
first by barack obama countries of
danger you know who supported
it syrian christians refugees who were
christians who made up less than one
percent of the migrants coming over
during that surge
despite the fact that the rest of them
were all islamic uh
military-aged men and you see what
happened in europe what do we have
banning diversity training critical race
theory in the federal government
okay sure these are the radical policies
they're talking about my point is
there is nothing there what reducing our
corporate tax rate
to just be on par with places like
sweden denmark nations that you guys
love and you
proclaim as the model of socialist
success
that's radical yeah the the only way
that this works is if you buy the lie
that everything that donald trump said
was racist and the only way that that
works is if you watch the clip that they
want you to watch right when it's edited
the way they want it to be edited
right that's the only way any of this
works and everybody had to carry the
water and they did
and we talked about divisive and radical
let's go through let's go through
biden biden wants to put our taxes to a
level that is unseen in the
industrialized world
supports black lives matter the
terrorist organization who on their site
demand the destruction of the nuclear
family
he said that antifa is just an idea he
wants to spy
on americans who may be too far right
wing we did an entire segment on that
that's not hyperbolic
so that they can use the government as a
political arm to target you and of
course not to mention
uh you he supports men who have been men
their entire lives and with
within one year beating the [ __ ] out of
women in sports and you want to
look barack obama to give you an idea
when we talk about
divisive barack obama went into
office he was whisked into office
opposing
gay marriage donald trump was the only
president
ever elected who had supported gay
marriage before
he went into office whether i agree with
him or not doesn't matter right now if
you were to go back to barack obama
meaning in 2008 2009 2010 i don't
remember when he changed his mind
for political expediency and if you were
to tell barack hussein obama
hey by the way you're going to have to
make sure that uh men with penises and
testicles
can fight women and compete at the
olympics you'd say no no come on you're
bringing up a straw man with your
[ __ ]
the 70s they want their politics back
seriously you think that anti-gay
marriage barack obama would have a chip
to compute
32 year old men breaking the orbital
bones of
of women and sports and we act like
donald trump is radical so donald trump
just says oh no no no i'm not going
no men compete with men women compete
with women right simple
yeah mine goes well you know however you
want to identify and women should just
get used to it and we have to redraft up
title ix
to protect women's sports but you know
and there's no this is
when it's when it is determined by what
you think you have to do to be woke
it inevitably becomes radical this is a
party that is politically beholden
to black lives matter antifa and kamala
harris
not to mention navarro i don't care how
many decades ago she was a republican
well and if they're doing all this crap
publicly
saying all this making these the issues
what do you think they're doing behind
your back
they're trying to screw you get your
money this is these are all these yeah
they just
they just the nonsense they throw out
there to make it seem like they care
that's what i i just
that's one of the things i hate about
politics yeah when will it get old right
when will it get old when somebody just
tells you what you want to hear but then
does something completely different
and you don't have the time to go and
look into the matter and see that they
did something different that's what
trump did differently too
he said i'm going to do this and he did
it yeah well let me let me tell you why
this is controversial okay
especially when and i'm i don't want to
be conspiratorial the only conspiracy
that i hold
is the whoever's in charge of the
photography for john travolta vhs tapes
because it's always the same picture i
don't think he's ever taken a new
headshot but we'll get to that that's a
whole other segment we're going to do
one day
however you follow the money segments
and you look at these international
and entire yeah an entire program you
look at these international corporations
right for the same reason that they
couldn't discuss china yeah for the same
reason that they couldn't discuss a lot
of these foreign issues because of
of uh basically them being beholden to
foreign financial actors let's put it
that way yeah
like the world health organization not
acknowledging taiwan i don't think this
is a conspiracy
when it happens in plain sight but i am
asking you to extrapolate that and apply
it a little bit
to places like cnn to places like you
know time warner to place it
things like disney universal right this
is a huge china is a huge market
okay when you look at the policies that
were most controversial
what most offends the media when they
say donald trump is divisive
is he committed the cardinal sin of
enacting policies that put
you the american first and i would even
say you the american woman first and
that you shouldn't have to compete
against men but let's even talk about
this
on a more geopolitical level okay donald
trump what do you do force canada
european nations to pay their fair share
of nato
what was the original agreement was it
two percent three percent they were
paying about point four
sources available at loudspreader.com
i'm going by rote right now uh he left
the paris agreement he left the world
health organization
keep in mind people saying i can't
believe he did that this was after the
world health organization said
no covet cannot transmit from human to
human they said that we do not advise
the travel bans
and they refused to acknowledge uh
taiwan
as as anything they hung up on they
acted like taiwan as this concept
metaphysical con concept
stuff on china terrorists brought jobs
back and what do you do he forced mexico
to stop migrants from coming over the
border by levying a tariff
these were the policies that were
considered impermissible and divisive so
just be clear it's not the media versus
donald trump and it's not the left
versus right
we know that the entire media with the
exception of maybe fox news and the
exception of a few shows like this right
yeah but
the entire mainstream media abcmccbsc
and msnbc
um they lean left it's the media
versus you it's the media versus
america first looking out for the
american and this is how you get to the
point where
no one would have believed that donald
trump a guy raised in the lap of luxury
wealthy his entire life beautiful
penthouses right you're talking about
beautiful private schools every
opportunity handed to him
somehow seemed more relatable to the
working man
than someone like joe biden who talks
about his boxing gym behind amy's diner
which never existed
and the reason for it is just because
donald trump look i think he had a heart
for the
average american and guess what the
average american was doing better white
black red and yellow black and white
there precious in his sight if you're
more offended at the red and yellow in
there
you should think about the precious in
his sight jesus loves the children of
the world
but you can go screw yourself my point
here is this is what happened
he believed that americans should come
first since he was the president of the
united states of america
and that was impermissible and so the
media attacked attacked attacked and
then they go look how divided we are i
really think you have a
if a former vice president right now is
putting america first but they don't
question him on any of it why
they don't want you to be put first
because that's not in their financial
best interest you're about to say
something there dave i thought no
i i forgot okay well uh this is also
something really important and i know
you're
hungry uh this is something really
important to biden of course former vice
president joe biden you don't have to
take my word for it you know levar
burton this [ __ ]
uh he's the laughing stock of the rest
of the world at this point we're not
more respected we all know that
and and the president of south africa
as as i said
i did not i didn't i i certainly didn't
how are your meetings going in cornwall
mr president
how are your meetings going here in
cornwall very well
yes i'm gonna play cornhole
yeah and that's not even we don't have
video but i think uh angela can bring up
the picture of macron
putting his finger in the face of
president look at this
look at this like a father scolding a
child donald trump would either break
that finger off or have somebody else do
it afterwards
excuse me french finger it is just you
really think we're more
this is the point you can't appease the
rest of the world by putting americans
last and expect them to respect you
no nation respects the leader of a
nation who doesn't put their own nation
first and
what's going on here dave i'm hungry
okay well look if you're that hungry we
have
we have built bars here i've told you
just go what do you mean we have build
bars yeah just go into the office get
yourself one come back hit the reset
button we've had billboards the whole
time yeah go get the whole time
yes go go get one now yeah go
[Music]
hey oh hey dave
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well uh billboard hey by the
way you can go right now to uh
buildbar dot com yeah answering but
feeling better oh
good and we make no me we make no claims
by the way did i heard manny again
dave's an outfit dave's an outlier
that's why he was removed from the
clinical trial
uh go to builtbar.com crowder15 you get
15
off look people have asked i don't
really i'm not a big believer in
supplements you don't need to eat
protein bars just to be clear however
these things taste like actual candy
they're very good so i ate a few of them
probably just at night so i don't eat
dessert
because you know i don't don't need any
more of this they want me to get down
below 2 30 for the surgery they're not
coming up
are you close and i um
i figured i'd get in the sauna in a in a
sauna suit and sweat it out are you
gonna cut for surgery
epsom salt bath chewing on a towel
filled with ice chips
uh so i do recommend honestly they are
delicious someone told me you could put
the bill bars in the freezer too
oh really and it's like a frozen
snickers i don't know the salted caramel
just tastes like one of those you can
also leave them in your car and ruin
them yes that's true that happens
right superman i'd say the coconut oh
are you a coconut guy dude i
i am with those yeah i'm not a big
coconut guy but i know people who love
coconut
love the love the coconut though those
are the that's what those people are
freaks
so so are people say divisive divisive
i know people have corrected me on that
that's it's very divisive
it also wasn't canada and they put a
line in and on in an
envelope an envelope
delivered uh by the way comment on what
your your opinion here on who was
actually more divine i want to know
objectively if you thought that donald
trump was more divisive versus joe biden
i think
again donald trump called out the liars
joe biden is a liar not saying that
donald trump is an angel believe me no
no we definitely understand that but
look joe biden is a useful idiot right
now on the world stage
they want him there there's a reason
that putin said the guy that
has killed people his job in the kgb was
to do that he said oh he's a moral man
do you think he gives a crap
about morality i he is a man that he can
manipulate so of course he would want to
keep him
exactly where he is yeah the world is
going to love us as long as we're weak
yeah you can just use them like a
wind-up doll yeah look at him
get
yeah i think the world also hated
churchill that turned out well for him
true make him ride unicycle
yes again he fell off right away
he's not good at writing unicycle what
do we do with him send them to michael
vick he'll take care of it
yes bed bath and beyond just no bed
you want you want michael vick to uh
what drown him in a we don't have a pool
just take kiddie pool turn him over he
will know how to fix
they take him to shark jail yes exactly
um by the way
we have a segment here before we leave
to uh mug club
the world health organization has been
watching the show just so we really
allegedly yeah we talked about something
yesterday that we pointed out and within
hours it was changed and we had the same
thing not long ago
with the children in covid but right now
um before we get to that this was this
was number one trend
all over social media here for a little
bit uh for a little bit of time online
and um a lot of people said they didn't
know who macy gray was which surprised
me
so zoomers yeah she she wrote in op-ed
advocating for a new national flag and i
know people say
why do you care it's not that macy gray
said this it's that a bunch of blue
verified checkmarks who are journalists
on twitter were saying why is this a
radical idea
yeah but you said a 23 corporate tax was
radical so i don't know i think
changing the emblem of our nation should
should qualify
so she said that we need a new national
flag in honor of juneteenth um i think
we have a clip
macy gray believes it's time for a new
flag to represent the united states of
america
in an essay shared on the stock market
news site market watch
macy shared her thoughts on why she
thinks the career is
and what it should be replaced with she
starts off her message by saying quote
the president madame harris and members
of the congress
the american flag has been hijacked as
code for a specific belief
god bless those believers they can have
it like the confederate it is tattered
dated divisive and incorrect
it no longer represents democracy and
freedom it no longer represents
all of us now okay first off this is
also the problem with um with very
stupid people and people
not calling them out as stupid unless
they be feared
let's say for the accusation of racism
let's just say it honestly she said
it is incorrect okay so that's a
statement that requires qualification
what is incorrect about the american
flag what what is the factual
error of the american flag are you
trying to say is it like another star to
be dc
right yeah well that's interesting in
puerto rico well
however that that doesn't mean that it's
incorrect it means
you're incorrect simply because dc is
not a state
nor puerto rico no so the truth is when
we're speaking factually you are
incorrect despite
obviously uh the qualifications that
must come with writing an op-ed
at market watch marketing about the flag
i don't understand it'd be like yaakov
smirnoff going on cnn right now
having a show to talk about the you know
criticized jugglers
what is happening here in country we
used to have good jugglers like he's
just not a pro she's writing about the
flag at market watch what are we
in russia balls juggle you bulls juggle
you
she has an embarrassment of freedom this
is the thing like she has so much
freedom that she has no idea what it's
like in the rest of the world you're
telling me that she has a lot of time
interesting but yeah she does
travel around the world and ask him
i'm killing him thinking about
swallowing assad oh well don't do that
i got no hit singles coming out of here
how do i get back
yeah i just say i haven't had a single
in here
yeah by the way that that symbol behind
you
[Music]
all right so you're right this symbol is
hateful no i did not say that
what i was saying that that stands for
freedom name a freer place on the planet
uh yeah we'll run that flag up the pole
if you can name that place
around words and it is not clear i have
no you know it's a good point
maybe luxembourg no well [ __ ] i don't
even
know what luxembourg is it's basically a
fake financial state where people get
your money
it's the only place in the world with a
higher average uh income than the united
states too because it's basically just a
bunch of bank it's not a real place
so here is the argument i want you to
see the argument that has been made from
the left supporting
of course macy gray it's not that macy
gray said it it's that people amplify
this and this goes back to the idea of
cancel culture
it's not that one person says this is
offensive it's that a bunch of other
people in positions of power
deem it offensive enough to get you
removed to take away your livelihood
in this case it's not that one singer
who hasn't had a single in years which
doesn't make her unqualified mind you it
just means that obviously this is
someone who is a useful pawn to the
media
and they choose which voices and which
opinions
warrant elevation for example if
uh uh what's that james woods has an
opinion right they go
washed up actor james woods who just had
a number one show not long ago and james
woods you'd be hard-pressed to find an
actor people don't respect as an
american or clint eastwood
clint eastwood who hasn't had a good
film since sully here's macy gray
yeah so that's that's the point see what
see what trickery is going on here so
these are some of the arguments that
i've heard people making as to why we
need to change the flag
and they're silly they hold no water um
one is well the flag's been redesigned
before
right we hear this this is all over
twitter we have dozens of designs of the
flags at the
i think you can bring this up the
collage at the philadelphia museum
why not now okay i don't know why i
should have to explain this
but we do a lot when you're a new nation
okay
and you're creating a flag obviously
some changes happen for example
you may not have the same number of
stars to represent states
when there are no states ah so
this is what happened details eventually
an agreement on the flag
that incorporated stars and stripes and
then eventually stars
into states and here's the thing too
when we change them um we change the
number of stars for example or the
layout of stars
to avoid the flag being cluttered right
aesthetically
it wasn't a change of what the flag
represented
let's there were no monumental changes
there weren't arbitrary changes of
colors
of symbolism of what the flag meant like
hey we had stars up there that represent
states
now they're going to represent uh
jefferson's horses that never happened
it's always been the same and when we're
this also matter when people say well we
added people to the supreme court
at one point and they don't talk about
the historical context the historical
context here is the flag that we have
right now with 50 states
is the longest standing flag it's been
there for
uh 61
years 61 years and then the last flag
right before it the only difference was
48 stars
47 years so really from 17 240 plus
years the flag has remained virtually
unchanged
outside of adding stars as we have new
states
well the circle right the circle which i
got upset when they change to the square
you know it's one of those things it's
kind of like when they decide with the
iphone to go
beveled to no bevel you're like what
what's modern is it rounded
is it angular i don't know i'm not in
the tron
fan club can have two circles
oh i'm just saying i spent a lot of time
getting dangerous
to the male symbols so we have to avoid
it i just showed that thing
next thing you know someone puts an
arrow in there and you're in trouble
macy grey and the left they wanted to
change colors uh they wanted to change
the symbolism reasoning because
again the reasoning was the current flag
is racist right
right this is something that's pretty
important they're saying we need to
change it we need to change the colors
we need to make it lgbtq aaip inclusive
we need to make sure that it includes
washington dc and puerto rico and this
is the issue with things like critical
race theory
it's a perfect example look in school
you should learn hey
when was america discovered hey
declaration of independence
hey what was the civil war when was it
when was the emancipation proclamation
signed
hey okay we had slavery why did we end
slavery
who opposed the abolition of slavery
what happened throughout the industrial
revolution right these are the things
that you should learn
when you start teaching children none of
that stuff is important
racism people have no foundation to
understand this is why we have the flag
this is why also other nations be it
world war ii be it other nations abroad
for example being burned alive in cages
christians in the middle east they are
scanning the horizon
in the hopes that the w the one beaking
of a shining light they could see on the
hill
is that stars and stripes because it
means something to them that's why more
people have
died trying to get here than anywhere
else
have you seen the boat some people have
tried to make trips from in cuba
they they're not even they're not only
not see whether they're not even buoyant
like car doors car doors and coolers
right
and because styrofoam but to them here's
the thing the cuban
american immigrant knows more about why
america
is america than macy gray of course like
you said her privilege her privilege
her freedom is embarrassing you can't in
the same breath
say hey it's racist for us to not to
have a wall
to not open up our borders to every
single caravan that wants to come here
and say
by the way our flag is a symbol of hate
it's a it's like the bethlehem star for
these people
and i understand it and that's why i'm
sympathetic to people who want to come
to this country
but they have to do it legally macy
gray's never thought about this
and more importantly the senior editors
at cnn and marketwatch and
forbes and newsweek it's asinine but
that's why you want critical race theory
in schools
because you want the asinine to become
normalized
yes this is like dating somebody who
just
you can't make happy right right just
keep feeling
like dating mason gray yeah like dating
mason gray but if you said you were
don't get me another album
right it doesn't matter what you do
though it's just more and more and more
every time they get something they want
it's something else that's oppressing
them
if you make it so they're not oppressed
then they have nothing to do
yeah so that's why the second you change
something it's just something else the
flag's like
what do you want us to do to the flag if
alf if al
sharpton woke up going rainbow over here
no i'm just wondering like what it
yeah no they wanted to be a skittles
commercial if al sharpton woke up
tomorrow
right and realized that racism was over
it would be like the first chapter and
left behind
oh yeah i woke up today with a job to do
but there don't seem to be no shoes
what are you saying it's empty what do i
do well you're basically useless
that's been a long time coming i want to
ask macy a question uh what flag design
did the union soldiers who freed the
slaves where
i don't know maybe that one maybe that
one would work yeah for you because
i think it's the same one that's sitting
right behind you right now no those ones
are
those people are racist hundreds of
thousands of people died
no no there was a there was a party
switch just ask robert
yeah just try and try and uh sift
through all the n-bombs he drops but you
know you'll find it
i have the other team's flag all over my
truck
also some roller blades i thought it was
like a just married decoration i don't
know
just gonna let you all know manny sent
over some pictures of
the garbage raft oh jeez that's terrible
yeah well i got to see them when i went
to guantanamo bay
well stephen what happened is they got
close to the border and they said have
you changed the flag yet yeah
you haven't we're not coming we're going
well they got close and it was just
it was just macy gray and a loud speaker
i wanna welcome you go back
yo turn around i don't
care that they take our saxophone
anything is better than this please
go back go away i love shabbos they're
just they're just like either sitting
there like an
ex-lover on batista's doors to please
yeah i know batista i know batista does
not it's an old regime shut up
so how to float away get eaten by a
shark
but at least it's not a racist shark was
it a tiger
or mako i'm getting esoteric
right now so america
is harder so you should build gallons
of water
so i just meant the milk jugs
[Laughter]
so here's another another argument i got
it hold on it's important okay
we can float over we can float over here
for hugs okay and a wrap made of milk
jugs
okay okay there you go that's what i was
going for
i was too busy laughing at the one you
had just added yeah worth the wait
look i'm not saying that was the best
i'm just saying
that works i appreciate yeah it's good
basically buffalo new york
yeah workshop it works buffalo new york
you can see me making macy great jokes
what's up with buffalo i don't know much
about your locality
that joke's why i'm performing in a
strip mall
[Laughter]
just be sure to buy now two drinks
because there
is a minimum drink all right
dear lord help does macy great just
happen to be in the strip mall she's
like what the [ __ ]
that's copyrighted um
[Laughter]
i don't have time for this [ __ ] this
matter manager's like actually according
to the schedule
uh you do all kinds of times a lot of
time i got nothing but time
so uh here's another argument that we
see from the left and i saw this all
over twitter again blue check marks and
people are like oh yeah listen for
people who say
uh the flag matters you don't want to
change it who fly the trump flag
or the thin blue line flag you've lost a
leg to stand on
um okay real is that is this now this is
an argument that
passes for the cnn room or the stephen
colbert writing look almost
always almost invariably when you see
the trump flag
or the thin blue line flag it's
alongside people
who also carry the american flag because
they don't deem it offensive right it
was never meant to replace the american
flag have you ever seen someone opine
that we need to do away with the
american flag
and replace it with the thin blue line
flag no not at all but because they
honor the flag and unlike macy gray in
the left who hate america which is why
they say donald trump was so divisive
because his policy
put america first starting to see the
threat here they
of course will not carry the flag look i
challenge you this
okay first off the maga flag right the
trump thing this is basically a bumper
sticker that was turned into a flag
you won't find rally donald trump
rallies or official rallies where people
are flying and there is an american flag
there okay
just won't happen usually i want you to
try this too see a truck with the thin
blue line flag or
look at houses but they have the thin
blue line flag count how many of them
in your neighborhood and comment below
are alongside the american flag now
for contrast i want you to count how
many
of the rainbow peter puffing flags are
alongside american flags because that is
something i've never understood
if you're gonna say that america is this
symbol of hate
and and oppression okay how many porches
do you think
in iran have the iranian flag next to
the lgbtq aip
zero next to the body hanging yes
that's really what it is so i don't i
don't understand it
i mean i get it it's because you hate
america because obviously we could
we could go through this rationally and
go well it seems to me you could still
love the rights and freedoms afforded
here in america and love penis and by
the way when
they're not mutually exclusive when
police officers say that basically being
killed for sitting in their car in the
wrong neighborhood it's it's kind of
okay to say hey i want to do something
to support you i'll fly the american
flag and the thin blue light oh you mean
like the people the organizations that
macy gray supports no black lives matter
yeah taking out police officers record
number of violence against police this
last year yeah
yeah oh okay we understand let's let
your flag fly by the way there is a
black lives matter flag and an ant of a
flag as well
okay and a gay flag that's what i mean
these flags do exist
you can put them up why do you have to
mess with the american flag because they
hate the united states
it's like just put up the flag you want
nobody said you couldn't yeah people
look this was tribalism
sure look i'm drawing the look i'm not a
centrist drawing a line in the sand when
you say we need to change the american
flag because it's racist
sexist homophobic and incorrect i say no
you are incorrect that's it and it
doesn't represent freedom that's the
dumbest part of this argument
it shows that you've done zero research
on the rest of the way i don't even call
it tribalism it's just patriotism yeah
at one point that used to be okay yeah
there's nothing wrong with that now it's
just now it's almost like drawing half
the christian fish you see an american
flag 90
chance they're a conservative that's the
reality that's true may not like it it's
true
all right unless you can make your own
flag yeah well actually we have an
exclusive look at
what macy gray's new flag looks like
it's aiming to be as inclusive as
possible
i think yeah oh i like it it's basically
just the
show to space odyssey with corporations
ah corporate sponsorship man i hate it
that's a good thing they're in
everything
i know i'm surprised i'm surprised as
well that it wasn't cool i know
but it's still funny well they're taking
away menthol we don't want to endanger
anybody
right yeah you're not reading one of
those labels because
you evidently it's always funny to me
this is this is how they do everything
wrong the government this is i remember
i went into an audition once
okay i don't know if people want this
little inside baseball but i went into
an audition with
one of the one of the most well-known
comedy casting agents
uh of our generation yeah and she was
like yeah and i heard i've seen some
stuff that you're more conservative
you know that's not really common in
this why is that i said well and this is
how i answered exactly
i said um without getting into detail i
tend to believe that individuals
uh when given the freedom and ability to
make their own decisions
do them more effectively relatively
speaking
to bureaucrats in dc and that's why i'm
a conservative and she said
oh well that's interesting i can
understand that don't ever say that if
you want to work in this industry
because most people aren't as tolerant
as i am is what she said
um and anyway you mean a lot of people
in hollywood though that are closets
right but this the point that i was
making there is i said that because
i truly believe the government almost
screws everything up generally speaking
the examples they tried out when they
try to say your social security check
that's a screw-up i mean how many times
we had to raid a slush fund
you know who else believes that though
that that principle that that you know
you just basically especially
democrats they just believe it with
religion right they believe that if
you're
human beings are generally good when
they're unshackled from
this oppressive god right my point was
the government here because we were
taught we started with cigarettes and
then i got all i got off on a
side track a tangent thanks dave and
your restless leg syndrome no no
seriously it's a disease this is the
think about this the fda um i think it's
cfd i don't know who else uh the tobacco
anti-tobacco lobbyists and all this
stuff yeah they got together okay
there was a meeting of the minds the
best and the brightest among us
let's be really clear and they said we
need to do something about smoking
because it seems that cigarette smoke is
bad for teenagers
and they said okay let's look at the
component this is the government keep in
mind our best and brightest
they looked at the cigarette they
probably had a little box moved it
around said okay
what is a cigarette got a white board
wrote it down okay right what's causing
harm what's calling harm okay
well what is the best thing that we
could do to try and curb behavior
without infringing on rights
i know we'll ban the menthol component
yes of the cigarette huh that seems to
be the primary offender here
also vape juice yeah this is the best
and brightest
put them in charge of your retirement
dumb asses
be more accurate the menthol it's the
same as like even i understood when and
when i was young even though whatever
the joe camel thing it's like
look it's a cartoon it appeals to kids i
understand menthol
cigarettes there's no reason it's like
spuds mackenzie who by the way
died of uh uh complication of liver
failure and hiv
oh wow that dog got busy i thought he
just i thought he just met michael vick
[Laughter]
he was already those were the ones who
were really bad fighters he slow killed
them that was his early days it's okay
though he did uh he passed out flyers at
the mall sputz mckenzie's just walking
into a michael vick party never walks
out
hey guys oh hell oh that's hilarious
any well and also not right um i don't
even know where i was going with that
what you were making earlier about that
moment
of that because you're going okay this
appeals to kids whatever i collected the
marlboro miles when i was like 14 yeah i
smoked i'm like
go and get me a pool table
it's ridiculous but that jacket i can
understand that but the taking away
menthol is
really i honestly see it as racist
really because it is it's a cigarette
that's more commonly smoked
by black people just a fact and if it's
something that somebody enjoy i'm not
saying you should do it
but if you enjoy it you're an adult
you're able to make that decision that
you're allowed to have a cigarette
right you should be able to have it
that's just my opinion wow
racist i just think i heard uh dave i
think i heard him say he's racist
no no i don't even think cool sells
non-menthols let's be honest
no it's true i started on newports
because i was like
come on quarterback of course more but
whoa
because you know what else you have the
fda studies they also said hey we want
to reduce
children smoking i understand that and
so they decided to include among
cigarettes
hand rolled eight or nine dollar cigars
along with like swisher sweets which by
the way a lot of these are philly sweets
they're
they tend to be smoked in uh i guess you
would the term they would urban
communities it's a cultural things has
been around for a while
but when they actually create when they
actually looked at the studies because
some people said hey hold on a second
you're talking about mom and pop
businesses where
a hand world cigar is very expensive we
very much doubt that kids in junior high
are purchasing 9 10 11 12 cigars
zero percent of children
no we're starting with hand-rolled
cigars
none well i started with the blackened
mouths but
that's a cigarette yeah it's a cigarette
like with a wooden but even with those
of course they're not using cigars
because when they buy a cigar it's a
swisher sweet to get wet
then open it up with a razor blade dump
out the tobacco fill it with pot and
have yourself a blunt party
yeah unless it's sea unless it's delta
well then i mean you don't want that
kind of potato no no
you don't have it just have this gummy
that'll make you see the devil's
dick that's a quote that's a direct
double blush now that is a that is a
direct quote okay what if it's not a
good dick
so here it is like angled weird yeah
you're like wow you gotta have something
you've got to have something
going for him for anyone to have
followed him in the fall that's true
that's true yeah he's like i know i'm
kind of a jerk of a mystery job but
i'm beautiful come on all right he did
bless me with one thing
i don't want to be getting the butt
vaccine um
so for people who are tuning in later it
was the president
of the philippines who threatened his
own citizens with a butt vaccine
in prison so this is something that was
brought to my attention yesterday gerald
you're going to be fired because you're
too much of a liability and then every
time you point something out
and it's linked at ladder with
credit.com as an official source
it changes i thought this is like ed
rooney's attendance
so computer on the show gerald mentioned
he was looking up something on his phone
and i want to be very very clear here
none of us are expressing any opinions
right now
at all because that would be
impermissible and of course those who
are
mud club members we'll talk later um on
the show
gerald covered uh that the who the world
health organization's vaccine guidance
on their own website
yesterday at the time of it was 11
o'clock
eastern maybe 11 o'clock yesterday
gerald pointed out this
the who did come out and say children
should not be vaccinated for the moment
this is from their website well [ __ ]
yeah
so yep yesterday by yesterday afternoon
yeah those giant bolded letters which
almost seems like they might be
important
some would say go on oh
gone we have it available at
lateralsquare.com we went through time
machine so you can see the previous day
and today now it is replaced with
non-bold children and adolescents tend
to have milder disease compared to
adults so unless they are part of a
group at higher risk of severe cova 19
it is less urgent to vaccinate them than
older people
those with chronic health conditions and
workers more evidence is needed on the
use of different covid19 vaccines for
children generally
uh to be able to make general
recommendations on vaccinating children
against here's the thing
yesterday you made a very clear
recommendation
that they should not be vaccinated and
let's be clear there have been
other national uh governing health
authorities that made it clear that
children should
not be vaccinated now today
well not today yesterday within hours
they said we can't make a recommendation
and this is the issue because we ran
into this same issue with the cdc
again not expressing any opinions can
you bring up bring up the overlay so i
don't get in trouble
where the original on cdc when we when
when this was said on air i'm just going
to read the cdc
it said the risk of complications for
healthy children is higher
for flu compared to coven 19. however
infants and children with underlying
medical conditions are at increased risk
for both flu and coven 19. the key there
is the risk of complications for healthy
children is higher for
flu compared to kova 19. when that was
quoted on
air that was the violation of
youtube guidelines not the quote exactly
they said it could be uh i think the
commentary
could be misinterpreted as though uh
covet isn't dangerous which is not true
this was on the cdc
website when we brought attention to it
then there's one hard strike later
the cdc changed it to read for young
children especially children younger
than five years old the risks of serious
complications is high for flu compared
to cova 19.
however sirius 19 illness resulting in
hospitalization and death
can even occur in healthy young children
they changed it to minimize well we
don't really know but here's what's
important
when you go from hey don't do x
don't vaccinate children right it's not
recommended to
uh we don't know what science for
talking about science what science
changed in three hours
is there a new study that we don't know
about this is all i'm saying
because i want to be able to trust the
scientific process the scientific
process should be
gerald says something at 11 a.m eastern
that's bolded
on the world health organization right
you just have to sort of you know you
have to you have to
uh sift through the taiwan doesn't exist
in the
comments but it's true you say it and
then within three hours they say oh we
don't have any info to make a
recommendation
so then either you made a recommendation
both based on bogus information before
or there's no new information and now
it's a political change
that is my point that is why you don't
have trust
in institutions it's not americans fault
it's yours well and i think they have to
be held account why did you make the
change
so you you owe an explanation to us
because i believe the the
that that link that page those
recommendations came out within the last
week maybe 10 days something like that
if i'm off by a little bit it's
definitely within this month right not
long ago
what you asked the question what changed
okay fine that's all i want to know now
you need to tell us
why you thought it was so important to
remove what is a very important part of
this the bolded sections tend to draw
people's attention on purpose because
this is where you need to focus your
attention then below it you explain what
the point is
you change that and then you change the
write-up form why and here's the issue
right now you are seeing this in real
time
because we've talked about this in the
past they switched on asymptomatic
carriers they switched on masks they
switched on double masks they switched
right on it being a lab leak you're
experiencing in real time
right now people trying to navigate
their lives and make decisions based on
information that changes arbitrarily
look
lest you claim i'm an anti-vaxxer let me
be really clear 97 year old grandma
who's had bronchial issues i wanted her
vaccinated as soon as humanly possible
okay why because i looked through the
information that had been provided
dad and we had a lot of data on older
people and specifically people who may
be immunocompromised
and of course the science seem to be
very clear that any risk
is worth the reward for them now we need
to be able to make this decision
in real time and before yesterday at 11
according to the world health
organization someone would look at and
go okay they're saying the sign says
don't do vaccinations for children and
you make that decision then it changes
three hours later
this is you're seeing it happen in real
time and then afterwards they say if
you're against
us you're against science did some of
you make that hey did some of you
look at the world health organization
and maybe cancel vaccinations with your
kids
and was that wrong to do what changed
what information is there
we know what the recommendations were
and we know they went away and this
happens all the time
and i don't know i don't want but you
mentioned on the show and then things
this happens all the time i had to look
at it like five times i actually tweeted
this out and i was like i wonder how
long this is going to take to be taken
down because i'm sure this is going to
go against their policy little did they
know that no it's like just i just took
a screenshot of the website yes and then
somebody pointed out to me i have to
give him credit for it it was just like
uh i think
i think something changed i was like
what i clicked the link and it was just
gone whoops
just absolutely gone that's unbelievable
with no explanation i want to know who
made the phone
call i want to know who made the phone
call and said hey you need to change
this because people are actually taking
what we say seriously and they're basing
their decisions off of it right
please change this really quickly to
something vague so they can't do it
anymore and i'm not even
i'm not even saying at this point i'm
not qualifying either
as dishonest no what i am saying is i
have no idea why there was one statement
and it was changed
this is not me just pulling a jesse
ventura asking questions just trying to
insinuate that there's a conspiracy
i actually want these answers right and
these are answers that only the world
health organization
that only the cdc that only people like
fouchy can give us you're on the grid
yes i i'm not off the grid i'm off the
grid because i have about half an acre
outside of saint paul where i i have a
block filter to avoid fluoride in this
app
half an acre i'm off the grid on my my
new television show on discovery
exactly you realize you can be more on
the grid than you
i was a navy seal where those things are
it was an underwater demolition unit but
it's the same damn thing
i haunted the predator
you know that i'm a real ass kicker if i
still manage to rise to some
manicum of fame with my riffraff hairdo
they usually don't let folks like us in
the door i'm just asking questions
all right we have to get going to talk
about things that we can't talk about
here and we're going to play hipster
hobo
if you're not a member sign up mug club
we have another 45 minutes of show
letters credit.com
mug club tomorrow cultural appropriation
month california i think we have michael
knowles on the show
if i'm not mistaken or is it brett
weinstein i don't know we have some
guests coming up
and no no hmm it's just a still of
gangrene
it's a forensic image um
send in your costumes we'll be taking
your costumes tomorrow california
cultural appropriation month youtube
piss off
you